wagon train father knows best and craft
Theatre will not be seen at their usual
times tonight so that we may bring you
the special telecast of the Motion
Picture Academy Awards following
immediately see father knows best at
9:15 and wagon train at 10:30 tonight
over most of these stations
Hollywood the 30th annual achievement
awards at the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences ladies and gentlemen
the president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences mr. George
Seaton
good evening ladies and gentlemen at
this time each year it is the function
of the president of the Academy to bring
you a message from our Board of
Governors this year the message is brief
but enchanting it is simply this
tonight our program is brought to you as
a public service and will not be
interrupted by commercials
the sponsors of the show waiting behind
this curtain are all segments of the
motion picture industry the creators the
producers the studios artists
representatives distributors and your
neighbors who own and operate the motion
picture theaters of America because
people who make movies also make news
the journalists of the world press are
here enforced this evening due to the
unprecedented coverage of this very
special event we have an innovation this
year we have erected this pavilion
adjacent to the stage stage door to
accommodate the reporters photographers
and newsreel men who were here to record
these activities after the winners and
the stars who present the awards leave
the stage they will be interviewed and
photographed in this area mr. Bill
Miller of Price Waterhouse & Company a
regular on this program is with us again
however because our show contains
elements of entertainment we have not
attempted in previous years
mr. Miller will save time by supplying
each presenter with a sealed envelope
immediately before his entrance mr.
Miller do you certify that all the
sealed envelopes are in this sealed box
and that nobody bonded or otherwise is
messed around with it well then let's
get started now as a movie fan myself
I'm pleased to present your first host
of the evening one of the few stars who
can fill a cinema scope screen lying
down
mr. Jane Stewart